l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est au président
christian jacob
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
depuis le premier jour de cette
législature
notre groupe parlementaire n'a cessé de
combattre la politique de françois
hollande et celles de ses gouvernements
vous avez conduit la france dans une
impasse votre bilan est calamiteux
et comme l'immense majorité des français
nous pensons que cette longue parenthèse
socialiste n'a que trop duré
dimanche dernier
des millions de français qui aspire à
l'alternance ont fait un choix clair net
et puissant ils sont donnés à françois
fillon une légitimité incontestable
légitimité
incontestable pour porter nos couleurs
nos valeurs et un vrai projet de rupture
pour la france
monsieur le premier ministre
les français attendent cette rupture car
ils ne supportent plus le spectacle
affligeant que vous même et le président
de la république donnait à la tête de
l'exécutif
[Applaudissements]
nous ne voulons pas que le gouvernement
de la france continue d'être la risée du
monde entier pendant les six mois qui
nous séparent de l'élection
présidentielle
personne n'imagine en effet qu'un
premier ministre nommé par le président
de la république ne lui soit pas loyal
jusqu'au dernière minute de son
quinquennat
dans ces conditions et compte tenu de
vos déclarations sidérante du week-end
allez vous déclarez votre candidat
toutes les présidentielles en ayant
monsieur le premier ministre une fois
n'est pas coutume le courage d'assumer
clairement vos ambitions et le courage
ça n'est pas le verbe sur le premier
ministre le courage c'est le courage de
faire
et si vous prenez cette décision dans
l'intérêt supérieur de nos institutions
vous engagez vous à démissionner
immédiatement maintenant merci monsieur
jacob la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre manuel valls
ne soyez pas impatients
on écoute la réponse monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le président jacob il y
a trois semaines à peine auriez vous
vous un instant monsieur le président
jacob imaginez appelé à voter françois
fillon contre alain juppé au deuxième
tour
auriez vous imaginé un seul instant ce
scénario ce qui devrait alors monsieur
le président jacob vous amenez non pas
sur les questions que vous me posiez
mais sur les pronostics et je relève en
tout cas un mot qui je crois ne va pas
l'un de vos collègues à l'époque l'avait
déjà prononcés différemment en parlant
des fractions il n'y a pas eu de
parenthèse socialiste ait eu un vote
souverain des français en 2012 qui ont
élu un président de la république et
c'est ça respecter la démocratie et
c'est surtout ne pas confondre et vous
le savez parfaitement une primaire avec
l'élection présidentielle elle aura lieu
dans six mois et laisser d'abord et
laissons d'abord les français choisir
vous le savez les pronostics dans ce
domaine là peuvent se tromper je vous
réponds au delà du zèle qui est le vôtre
de nouveaux convertis qui ont tant de
péchés à se faire pardonner
je vous réponds parce que je suis là je
vous réponds parce qu'il n'ya pas de
crise institutionnelle et je suis là
comme je lé fais depuis que je suis
premier ministre pour défendre assumer
l'action gouvernementale qui est la
nôtre pour critiquer et m'opposer
désormais mais c'est normal c'est le jeu
de la démocratie
après une primaire réussie je veux le
rappeler mais en regardant de très près
les arguments qui ont été utilisés entre
les deux tours en regardant de très près
le projet de françois fillon qui dit
vouloir pleinement l'appliquer c'est
vrai sur la suppression des cinq cent
mille fonctionnaires dont alain juppé a
dit que c'était pas possible et pas
crédible c'est vrai pour la
privatisation de la sécurité sociale
c'est vrai pour le déremboursement
d'emilie des médicaments c'est à dire
des mesures qui concerneront les plus
modestes dans notre société il vous
plait réponse ionel parce que de toute
façon ma conception des institutions
c'est l'engagement et la loyauté il n'y
a pas de crise institutionnelle monsieur
jacob parce que je suis là pour
critiquer le projet de françois fillon
parce que je suis là aussi avec tous
ceux aujourd'hui dans la majorité pour
défendre un projet pour la france
[Applaudissements]